I've been doing some thinking I'm gonna
kill my dad I called my sister listen
kill dad I'm gonna take him to Oregon
find some heroin and give it to him my
dad has fronted temporal lobe dementia
or STD it's a confusing disease it hits
people in their 50s or 60 it can
completely change someone's personality
making them paranoid and even violent my
dad has been sick for a decade but three
years ago he got really sick and we had
to move him out of his house the house
that I grew up in the house that he
built with his own hands
my strapping cool dad with the falsetto
singing voice had to move into a
facility for round-the-clock care when
he was just 65 at first my mom and
sisters and I made the mistake of
putting him in a regular nursing home it
was really pretty it had plush carpet
and afternoon art classes and a dog
named Diane but then I got a phone call
miss Malone we've arrested your father
what well he threatened everybody with
cutlery and then he yanked two curtains
off the wall and then he tried to throw
plants out the window and then well he
he pulled all the old ladies out of
their wheelchairs all the old ladies
what a cowboy after he got kicked out of
there we bounced him between a bunch of
state-run facilities before finding a
treatment center specifically for people
with dementia
at first he kind of liked it but over
time his health declined and one day I
walked in and found him sitting hunched
over on the ground wearing a onesie this
kind of outfits that zip in the back I
watched him for about an hour as he
yanked it it
trying to find a way out of this thing
and it's supposed to be practical but to
me it looked like a straitjacket and so
I ran out I left him there i sat in my
truck his old truck hunched over this
really deep guttural cry coming out of
the pit of my belly I just couldn't
believe that my father the Adonis of my
youth my really dear friend would think
that this kind of life was worth living
anymore were programmed to prioritize
productivity so when a person an Adonis
in this case is no longer productive and
the way we expect him to be the way that
he expects himself to be what value does
that life have left that day in the
truck all I could imagine was that my
dad was being tortured and his body was
the vessel of that torture I got to get
him out of that body I got to get him
out of that body I'm gonna kill dad I
called my sister Beth she said you don't
want to live the rest of your life
knowing that you killed your father
and you'd be arrested I think because he
can't condone it and you don't even know
how to buy heroin I'm straight the truth
is we talked about his death a lot when
will it happen what will it be like but
I wish that we would have talked about
death when we were all healthy what does
my best death look like what is your
best death look like but my family
didn't know to do that and my sister was
right I shouldn't murder dad with heroin
but I gotta get him out of that body so
I went to a psychic and then a priest
and then a support group and they all
said the same thing sometimes people
hang on when they're worried about loved
ones just tell them you're safe
and it's okay to go when you're ready so
I went to see dad
I found him hunched over on the ground
in the onesie he was staring past me and
just kind of looking at the ground I
gave him a ginger ale and just started
talking about nothing in particular but
as I was talking he sneezed from the
ginger ale and the sneeze it jerked his
body up right sparking him back to life
a little bit and he just kept drinking
and sneezing and sparking over and over
and over again until it stopped and I
heard hey this is so fabulous this is so
fabulous his eyes were open and he was
looking at me and I said hi dad
and he said hiya Beth and I opened my
mouth to tell him right dad if you want
to die you can die we're all okay but as
I opened my mouth to tell him all I
could say was dad I miss you and then he
said well I miss you too and that I just
fell over cuz you're just a mess so I
fell over and I sat there with him
because for the first time in a long
time he seemed kind of okay and I
memorized his hands feeling so grateful
that his spirit was still attached to
his body and in that moment I realized
I'm not responsible for this person I'm
not his doctor I'm not his mother I'm
certainly not as God and maybe the best
way to help him and me is to resume our
roles his father and daughter
and so EDA sat there calm and quiet like
we've always done
nobody was productive both of us are
still strong okay dad I'm gonna go but
I'll see you tomorrow okay he said
hey so pretty nice Hacienda thank you
[Applause]